so joe trotted out there or hobbled out
there
and uh and proceeded to explain that gun
violence in the united states is an
international embarrassment
i do love it when presidents of the
united states talk about how the united
states is an international embarrassment
first of all i don't care what the
europeans think of us and i'm frankly
confused by anyone who does care what
the europeans think of us
why would i give a damn what the
europeans think of us after hundreds of
years of international warfare and then
saving their ass from the soviets i
really could not care less
what the french think of our gun laws in
the united states the french can stick
it
like i i don't care why would i possibly
care what china thinks
of our gun violence problem china is too
busy
locking up uighur muslims in zhang jiang
and why would
like who why why would i care how about
if i judge our policy based on whether i
think the policy
does a good job of balancing risk reward
and rights how about that
the constant appeal by democratic
politicians to what the world thinks
i don't care i don't understand why you
would care
you're a member of the american
democracy if you want to live in denmark
go live in denmark if you care that much
with the what the
folks in the netherlands think you are
free to pick up and leave at any time
i don't let me explain i don't give a sh
like i don't care but here is a joe
biden explaining that we should deeply
deeply care about what the international
community thinks of our gun violence
from listen if you want to make the case
that we ought to curb guns the least
effective case here is
yeah what do the australians think who
cares here's joe biden
trying to string together a sentence gun
violence
in this country is an epidemic no let me
say it again
gun violence in this country is an
epidemic
and it's an international embarrassment
and people clapping for that okay first
of all it's not an epidemic
you know it's an epidemic an epidemic we
just had one
we just had a giant global pandemic it
is finally coming to an end
gun violence is not an epidemic because
epidemics there are things where
you have a disease and then you pass the
disease to someone else
no matter how many acts of gun violence
are committed in the united states it
will not make me commit an act of gun
violence randomly because it was passed
to me on a bus
and that this sort of language is so
stupid it's like the cdc director today
said that racism is a public health
problem
no racism is a problem of the human
heart that has impacts in a wide variety
of areas it's not a public health
problem and gun violence is not an
epidemic
stop making comparisons between things
that are not comparable okay but it's on
the basis of stupidities like this that
he's gonna push forward a bunch of
crappy
executive actions on guns joe biden then
continues along these lines
right but but the entire point here is
that joe biden doesn't actually have
as we'll see any sort of rationale for
his gun control proposals here
there's no shot in the world they
actually lower the amount of violence
using guns in the united states they're
not calibrated to do that they are
calibrated to please the radical left
that has again a complete disconnect
with reality when it comes to the causes
of violence using guns
they believe that the way that you stop
violence using guns is by barring
obscure
sort of things that are used by some gun
owners without a lot of
connection to crime the actual way that
you stop gun violence is the same way
you stop all violence you put more cops
on the streets that's precisely the
opposite of what they want to do
so what is this really about if it's not
about curbing the amount of violence
using guns
and i i say violence using guns rather
than gun violence for a reason
there is a difference gun violence
implies the gun is responsible for the
violence which is idiotic
it's like seeing a knife of violence
it's like bomb violence
no there's violence that uses these
things as instrumentalities
in any case what really is driving this
what's driving this is the american
people think that joe biden has the feel
because that's all he's there to do guys
he's the comforter in chief sure he's
pushing radical policy
but he's the comforter in chief he's
just he's the most feeling
generous emotionally deep human who's
ever
walked the planet you know who will tell
you this the joker kamala harris
president joe biden is a leader with
great will great determination
and even greater empathy he has seen the
grief
of all of those who have lost a loved
one to gun violence
it is for them for all of us
that he will never ever give
up on this fight hey you know what's
really funny about this remember when
vice president
pence used to do this kind of stuff with
trump you get out there and talk about
how trump was just the greatest human
who'd ever lived
and the entire media be like look at
this sick of him look at him over here
just massaging trump well kamala harris
does this and everybody's like she's
amazing
she's just incredible it's by the way i
don't care
about i don't care might be a theme of
today's show i don't care about how
empathetic joe biden is i don't look to
joe biden for empathy i look to him to
be president of the united states and to
fulfill his constitutional duty
if i want empathy i'll get a dog if i
want empathy
i'll go to my wife i'll go to my kids
i'll go to my friends i don't need
empathy from the president of the united
states and if you're looking for empathy
from your politicians let me suggest
that your life needs some fulfillment in
it
if the place that you get your feels is
from the politicians you support
you're creating a golden calf and then
worshiping it
the white house comments director made
the same point however biden feels
feels about this he has feelings guys
i mean sure those feelings might have
some ramifications by making tens of
millions of americans
felons for owning stuff that they
already own but um he has feelings and
that's the important thing
he's somebody throughout his entire
career in public service
who has been incredibly focused on gun
reform you know he worked to pass the
brady bill when he was in the senate he
worked to pass the assault weapons ban
uh this is something he feels incredibly
powerfully about uh and so
the actions he's announcing today um are
are the first step
he would be the first to say it's not
enough you'd be the first to say this is
what they always say it's not enough
it's not enough as a substitute for it
doesn't do anything that we want it to
do
right if it's not just not enough it
doesn't it's not calibrated to solve the
problem
because what is the actual problem the
actual problem is that we have this
incredible rise in crime across the
united states that's been happening over
the course
of the last year emma tucker and peter
nichias over at cnn reported just a few
days ago quote
the u.s saw significant crime rise
across major cities in 2020 and it's not
letting up
major american cities saw a 33 increase
in homicides last year
as a pandemic swept across the country
millions of people joined protests
against racial injustice and police
brutality and the economy collapsed
underway to the pandemic a crime search
that has continued into the first
quarter of this year you may have
noticed in the description of the
problems last year
they did not include police were put
under the gun and then we're told not to
police anymore
okay that would be the actual reason not
the pandemic because it turns out that
in a lot of other areas of american life
and a lot of other areas of the country
that are not major metropolitan areas
crime actually went down
because people were staying at home okay
but
the real reason that this is happening
of course is because if you
rip on the cops all the time and then if
you try to defund the cops and there
aren't enough cops on the streets
violence goes up you may notice major
american cities saw that 33
increase in homicides those are all
democratic areas it is difficult to name
a major american city in the united
states that does not vote democrat
okay the ones that are that are having
the major spikes and crimes are the ones
that already like joe biden
that already like his policies many of
them have the same gun control policies
that joe biden already wants nationally
okay the real answer to the violence
with guns problems is the same as the
solutions the violence problem generally
which is you need
more cops on the streets 63 of the 66
largest police jurisdictions
saw increases in at least one category
of violent crime in 2020 that includes
homicide rape robbery and aggravated
assault
according to a report produced by the
major cities chiefs association
baltimore city baltimore county raleigh
north carolina did not report increases
in any of the violent crime categories
cnn says it's nearly impossible to
attribute any year-to-year change in
violent crime stats to any single factor
and homicides and shootings are an
intensely local phenomenon that can
spike for dozens of reasons but the
increase in homicide rates across the
country is both historic and
far-reaching
as were the pandemic in social movements
well it ain't the pandemic
that pandemic is not the rationale for
why people are murdering each other the
reason is because when you take the cops
off the streets
and when you say the cops are bad when
you have 20 million people in the
streets marching against the cops the
cops stopped doing their jobs we had a
bit of this in 2014 2015 with the
so-called ferguson effect
after ferguson missouri and now we are
having this with the george floyd effect
okay that is that is what is happening
but joe biden is not interested in
solving that problem
in fact joe biden is interested in
precisely the opposite the actual answer
to the rising crime would be more cops
you know who used to know this joe biden
joe biden was partially responsible for
that 1994 crime bill that he now derides
as having been racist but that 1994
crime bill was instrumental in bringing
down the crime rate in historic fashion
in the united states crime rates in the
united states
soared from essentially 1968 to 1994 and
then they started to come down
why because localities and states put
more cops on the streets and there's
greater
greater federal funding available to put
cops on the streets you know he used to
know that
joe biden well now joe biden is pushing
precisely the opposite according to
msnbc
biden's new gun proposals are interested
in investing in community-based solution
not incarceration except of course for
the fact that if you want
criminals off the street incarceration
would actually be the solution to that
particular problem
the administration will also invest in
evidence-based community violence
intervention rather than
incarceration okay well that is not the
solution okay in fact none of this is
really designed to be
the solution so what exactly are these
executive actions
according to the daily wire in a
statement the administration outlined
the following initial actions in his
attack on gun rights one
the justice department within 30 days
will issue a proposed rule to help stop
the proliferation of ghost guns
so ghost guns are basically you buy a
gun kit with the parts and then you put
it together yourself
let me just express that there is very
little evidence that ghost guns are
responsible
for a large share of violence using guns
in the united states
okay i'm unaware of any data suggesting
that ghost guns are a major problem
in terms of criminals who are using guns
in the united states beyond that
3d printing basically makes this
completely irrelevant
3d printing which is going to become
more and more prevalent in the united
states
means that you can simply cut the parts
yourself
using a blueprint online and it is a
crackdown on the first amendment to take
that stuff offline
it's a real problem it's a first
amendment issue if you're saying you're
going to take the plans to build a gun
offline for do-it-yourselfers at home so
is that designed to really solve a
problem
is there any evidence that taking
quote-unquote ghost guns out of
circulation
is number one going to be effective and
number two
is in any way supportable under the
second amendment that's a really
difficult case to make
second the justice department within 60
days will issue a proposed rule to make
clear when a device marketed as a
stabilizing brace effectively turns a
pistol into a short-barreled rifle
subject to the requirements of the
national firearms act
okay this particular provision with
regard to stabilizing braces apparently
there are 10 to 40 million
stabilizing braces in circulation
basically a stabilizing brace
is a device that you attach to the end
of an ar
pistol and it straps to your arm right
it doesn't straps your shoulder
that make it a rifle joe biden said
yesterday
that it makes it more deadly than rifle
i have no idea where he's getting this
uh or as deadly as a rifle it makes it
more accurate maybe um but really it's
there to to
kind of prevent the recoil from being as
large
in any case here was here is joe biden
ripping on on gun braces is that like
have we seen a wide variety of wide
spate of violent crimes using guns
in which the the gun brace was really
the problem here is joe biden on this
particular policy a third change
we want to treat pistols modified with
stabilizing braces
with the seriousness they deserve a
stabilizing brace hook and a pencil
essentially
makes that pistol a hell of a lot more
accurate and a mini rifle
as a result it's more lethal effectively
turning into a short barreled rifle
okay i have a question does he have any
data to show that it's more lethal than
a normal handgun
because the lethality of the handgun is
essentially rooted in two factors how
experienced you are with the handgun and
the muzzle velocity
that's pretty much it neither of those
two things is really affected by the
stabilizing brace per se
again he's what he's doing this is all
for show so much of this is for show
according to daily wire the portion of
the statement that mentioned the
stabilizing brace is a reference to ar
and ak pistols which have
barrels that are shorter than the
minimum 16 inches required by the
national firearms act the statement said
the pistols with an arm brace are
concealable
that's really not true because again
that means that ar pistols would be like
two feet long maybe it's concealed one
like a backpack or something but
certainly not
on your body they claim that weapons
with a pistol brace will be quote
unquote subject to the requirements of
the national firearms act
means gun owners will likely be forced
to pay a 200 tax stamp
on those firearms
other things that the the executive
orders are going to do they're going to
publish
model red flag legislation for states
that means nothing
because guess what states that don't
want to pass that are not going to pass
it states that do want to pass red flag
legislation
already will have done it so a lot of
this is just
for show a lot of this is basically just
a big nothing
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe
button so you stay up to date on all of
our future content